yeah did you see jordan peterson's
interview with decker aiken head from
the times
and then the subsequent write-up yeah
what were you thoughts on yeah
i didn't see it all to be fair so i i
saw michaela's
um response to it and um
i mean it was quite of i mean but the
the snapshots i heard because i heard
some of the recording
and i could tell that this was a hit
piece even even before reading the
the final i could tell that the the
there was there was something about the
smugness of the tone and the kind of
combative nature of the interview that
you knew that this person had already
decided in advance what they thought
about this situation they were going to
say what they thought about it and then
having read uh what what what actually
happened
uh yeah i mean it's it's a hit piece
that's what it is it's it's someone who
is not going in in good faith
and i think it's it's the wrong way to
go about an interview if you're going if
you if you're serious about
being an interviewer you need to sort of
coax out some truths about that person
or
get them to reveal some things about
themselves not use it as an opportunity
to smear someone and particularly with
someone like jordan peterson who let's
face it
has probably been mischaracterized more
than anyone else except for perhaps
jk rowling the two of them are right up
there as
people who've you know when you see the
level of vitriol
against them and the accusations that
are thrown against them
you know particularly with jordan
peterson who is someone who isn't even
really that political
um all of this stuff is weird because
you read it it bears no resemblance to
reality and this is what i'm talking
about
when they say about arguing people who
are capable of argumentation someone who
is willing to just completely
mischaracterize
and not provide evidence for their
mischaracterizations you can't
talk to that person it's like talk to a
madman there's no point in debating
someone who's who's literally in in
living in their own reverie
their own vision of what the world they
would like the world to be and that's
unfortunately where you are with someone
like that i've been in discussions
with people online about jk rowling
talking about all the transphobic things
she said
and whenever i said can you quote me
something transphobic she said
they could never can i mean the fact
that they never look at jordan peterson
same thing same thing right exactly
precisely the same thing
well in in a sense it's worse because uh
you have
you have most of his old lectures are
online so you have a
a a verifiable record of a man whose
opposition to tyranny in all its forms
including nazism
could not be better documented so the
idea that then you can then say
oh he's supportive of nazis it's it's
it's so
it's not even something you can debate
because it is just so fundamentally the
opposite of the truth
there's no point in getting involved in
that you know so it is infuriating but
that's the point which you have to say
no well i'm stepping back from this
conversation this isn't someone
this the the problem is that so many of
these people who are living in this
hallucin
hallucination of of a society of a world
are pretty prominent commentators uh and
interviewers for various major
newspapers so
it's it's it's it's frustrating because
you have to
i suppose what i'm saying in short is
the adults just need to start talking to
each other and let the kids
you know have their little tantrums and
let them get on with it but the adults
need to talk to each other
i mean you think with someone like
decorating head who's like lead
invest interview reporter or whatever
for the times you think that she would
have been one of the adults
i don't know much to be fair i don't
know much about her
but i think i'm perfectly prepared to
concede because of my lack of knowledge
of her work that she is actually a very
sensible
intelligent journalist and on this
occasion she allowed her passion to
overwhelm her reason
uh i mean that is a conflict that that
lives in the heart of all of us
um and we're all likely to to fall prey
to it
if if we have a a particular bug bear
about something or if we are
uh if we have i mean all of us at any
given time have
false perceptions in the world the the
key is never to lose society
of your objectivity and i think uh but
it but but it is undoubted
and certainly the case that in that
particular interview
uh she didn't behave in a professional
way and let herself down and the result
was a poor piece of journalism
well i mean is the interesting thing now
talking about freedom of speech not that
she is permitted to write
that swath of unrepresentative
maligned um very preconceived ideas
about a man who 15 minutes into the
interview
has to take a break to go and cry
in 15 minutes in breaks down talking
about how
other people have been positively
affected by his work
and the only reason that we're even
given any notion of that is that
michaela had the foresight to actually
record the call
so that they can then put it up to see
do you know what i mean yeah
didn't she say something in the
interview about how he's not in touch
with his emotions or he doesn't have any
emotion there was something in there
relating to it was it was yeah it was it
was obviously
well that's the thing about peterson in
particular as well he's obviously not a
confrontational
combative person no right he really
isn't and this this
um view of him as someone who's who's in
it for the fight and gets
stopped gets off on on the fight is is
probably not true i know who knows it's
not true
look at what he's saying during the very
very first set he breaks the fourth wall
he obviously thinks at least stepping in
that this decker lady is
on side in one form or another and i'm
gonna guess that having been through the
sort of hell of all of the rehab and the
trips around the world and all that
stuff that he's had to do
they'll have filtered this very very
very carefully to think right are we
going to be okay
is this the sort of thing that dad's up
to it's obviously going to be worthwhile
it's the times it's reputable it's blah
blah blah he's got the new book coming
out
and he breaks the fourth wall early on
in that and says um
i i've every time that i have one of
these combative interviews
um i have to take a rest afterwards
almost i feel sort of physically drained
once it happens
so he's saying to her look like i know
that you're sort of not a part of that
and then slowly over time obviously that
hope just gets chipped away yeah man i
mean like michaela's a good mate and
i i really feel like that family just
like if anyone's had enough like reason
after the problem is that that because
so much of
of i hate thinking in terms of sides but
i think i i just see so much evidence of
of those who are you know completely
enamored
of this social justice ideology they're
very quick to dehumanize people they're
very quick to demonize i mean
that they to the extent that they don't
care if people die and will gloat
if someone dies who doesn't agree with
them and that that
that to me is an inhuman way you've lost
your humanity well as soon as you start
doing that
you're not really a human being in any
serious sense in terms of your
uh emotional capacity you're you're like
you you've made yourself
you've made yourself ironically into the
the sort of a version of the person
you're projecting
um onto these other people and and
that is very sad and i think the [ __ ]
cruelty
of someone who who can see someone who's
obviously been through serious medical
problems
and yet you want to kick them when
they're down is uh uh
it is actually unfathomable to me i
don't i i can't imagine
i can't imagine ever getting myself into
the sort of place ever
ever where that would be the sort of
thing man like that type of journalism
that sort of like
very i don't know like if you if if
piers morgan lost
50 iq points and was 20 years ago like
that's the sort of
that still kind of like playing the heel
but with absolutely no charm to it
with no sort of good will that's the
sort of person
i don't know what decker aitkenhead
looks like but i imagine that it's kind
of like a younger piers morgan with a
wig
and like a little bit more frumpy i
don't know what she looks like i
i thought she was older though i thought
she was more established um i
i don't know to be fair but um
i suppose what what i think it is is
yeah i mean it it depresses me when i
think about the way in which people
allow themselves to become
these monsters which is what you know
unless you have empathy
empathy has got to be the bottom line
unless you unless you and
i think because identity politics has
become so tied to identity now
that it means that if someone is uh
challenging a world view instead of
welcoming that i mean you should you
should welcome it
and instead of welcoming it you you see
that person as a kind of
as someone who is the embodiment of evil
someone who is therefore threatening
uh your your identity who you are and
and committing violence simply by
disagreeing with you
then it's very easy to to to get
yourself in a situation where you can
you can see that person is less than
human
and expendable and uh and that is really
at the heart of cancer culture isn't it
this idea
that we you know if we could just get
rid of these people who think
differently than us because well
something that peterson himself talks
about is the way in which
when you are challenged it feels painful
it's a kind of uh
if you have to change your mind and you
get this shock of awakening and
it's a difficult process to be
open-minded to be a free thinker to
challenge yourself and be challenged by
others all of that is really difficult
um but rather than accept that actually
this is a positive form of growth
you know that that kind of those many
form of destructions are
a positive thing for yourself as an
individual
is to get rid of and eliminate any
possibility that it could happen it's
tied up with the whole idea of the safe
space culture the idea of
not being challenged and not being um
exposed to ideas that might be
uncomfortable what they mean by
uncomfortable is challenge you
make you a better person make you a more
interesting and well-rounded person
we have to in a sense start from scratch
all of this stuff has to we know
it means the universities schools
everything's got to basically start from
scratch again
um because at the moment we are in this
inc you know this wilderness of tigers
where
and where there's no sensible
discussions going on everyone's out to
hurt each other
no one's wanting to listen uh they're
just having their own
individual scraps with imaginary
enemies it can't go on forever
you